incredible stunt team was providing the
actors with skills they needed and kendo
obviously was an approach that allowed
them to bring to life who's been tense
fight free Declan one of our trainers
trained in kendo and he was really
particular about stars about the
mentality posture the footman is the
speed at which you move your feet
there's a very specific strikes but it's
really the focus where you have the
clarity and that calmness to it it's a
spiritual thing like Kenda is great to
have those close Corps combat kind of
removes so element of danger and it's
fast its aggressive at the same time and
as an image it looks really really
beautiful in a sense and I think that's
what JJ's gonna catch on
for me the thing that was the most
powerful with a lightsaber aside from
the original trilogy useless pieces they
were incredibly emotional and very
powerful and force awakens we try to
approach it from a point of view of a
rougher more primitive kind of fight as
opposed to more exactly
hey youtubers it's Charlie we're almost
at Star Wars The Force awakens some of
you are actually probably seeing it
right now but Mark Hamill just did this
big ESPN special about the evolution of
the lightsaber fight from you know
episode 4 to 6 and then episode 1 to 3
and then they talked a little bit about
what's going on in Star Wars The Force
awakens so I'm mostly going to focus on
the new stuff there is a new round of
the Star Wars giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video it's to IMAX
gift certificates so it's like a $50
value I think so here we go most of you
probably know that the Star Wars
lightsaber fights are based on the kendo
style of fighting the way they hold the
blades with two hands Mark Hamill will
sometimes tell the story of during
Return of the Jedi because Luke had
gotten so much better with the
lightsaber he kept asking George while
they were filming the scenes hey can I
use one hand because I could actually do
some really crazy choreography if you
just if you let me let go with one of my
hands and George Lucas was adamant he's
like no you absolutely have to be
holding the lightsabers with both hands
the reasoning was that they were
supposed to be incredibly heavy like
lightsabers were supposed to weigh a ton
the logic aside Rey Park said that when
he was working on his Darth Maul style
when he was gonna use the double bladed
lightsaber he actually had to make the
hilt way longer than George Lucas
originally intended like originally it
was like a really small lightsaber with
just two blades sticking out the Rey
part very wisely told him that look you
know look if I were to try and swing
this around the way you want me to I
would slice the crap out of myself so
after he explained the mechanics of a
double bladed weapon to George Lucas he
kind of relented so he wound out with
Darth Maul's giant hilted double bladed
lightsaber which actually looks very
similar to Ray's staff now raised staff
is supposed to just be a staff so I
think that you know there's a lot of
Tusken Raiders staff imagery in there
along with Darth Maul double bladed
lightsaber but the fights themselves
especially when they got to the prequels
like so much extra attention was laid
into the fights just because it was
supposed to be Jedi and their prime so
their style would be much more refined
they tried to turn the fights into like
mini stories in and of themselves like
the fight itself told a story it wasn't
just them fighting because they wanted
to kill or defeat someone so it's almost
like this interpretive dance thing like
you know let the blade do the talking
let the gun do the talking that sounds
like something Han Solo would do just
speak with his blaster but if the style
of the lightsaber fights and the
prequels was really evolved JJ Abrams
said that because of the state of the
force and in the state of Jedi
teachings where we are in the force
awakens in Episode seven the fights are
way more primitive way more brutal like
kylo Ren versus Finn here Luke had
already received a lot of training from
Yoda when he went up against Vader even
though he was very inexperienced got his
ass handed to him
but even though Luke and Finn don't
really know a lot they're not really
learn it in lightsaber kata it's all
based on the spiritual and physical
teachings of kendo so take that and then
throw in personality like they add the
characters personalities and that kind
of informs their personal style but it
all flows from the same energy as the
force now I feel like we're all in
agreement that this lightsaber that finn
is wielding is anakin skywalker's but
kylo Ren's lightsaber is way more
interesting to me at least right now
before I've seen the movie I have I
haven't seen it yet as I'm making this
video but with the producers JJ Abrams
everyone behind the movie has clarified
is that this is not a cross guard saber
those are just exhaust ports for excess
heat the lightsaber itself tells you a
lot about kylo Ren and his personality
teachings cobbled together in the
absence of a really strong Jedi Master
super hot-headed super brutal think
about the way Vader reacts to people
that he doesn't like like he's very
casual with it forced choking the
out of people kylo Ren much more
hot-headed because just like Luke
whenever he fought Vader was very
inexperienced
kylo Ren himself not a Jedi Master
probably not even a full dark Jedi
Knight or Sith however you want to think
about it so when you're watching the
characters just think about the way they
fight and how that flows from the same
type of energy that how the characters
throw their own spin on that based on
their personalities and even how each
fight tells its own story independent of
like the larger story the narrative the
problem here is like I'm posting this
video is that very few people have seen
the movie so like we could surmise a lot
of things about what's going on between
Finn and kylo Ren here finn using anakin
skywalker's lightsaber kylo ren really
wanting it being a vader fanboy but just
avoid potential spoilers if you do want
to talk about like what might be going
on with kylo ren's character in the
movie please use spoiler tags because a
lot of people won't get to see the movie
for at least another week I think New
Zealand is getting at first some of you
guys should be seeing it tonight America
gets it Thursday at midnight so I'm not
gonna see it for at least another day
and a half or so then I think China is
supposed to be the last country to get
it and that's not to like the beginning
of January so I'm gonna do a bunch more
Star Wars videos I'll do a non-spoilery
review
with absolutely no spoilers in it then
I'll do a separate spoilery review just
just in case it'll be all kinds of Star
Wars all weekend long it's gonna be so
much fun let me know in the comments
though what is your favorite lightsaber
fight in all of Star Wars you know from
the prequels to the Clone Wars like
anywhere at Star Wars even the comic
books I feel like a lot of people's
favorite might be Yoda versus Sidious
but there was actually this panel from a
Star Wars comic book recently where a
whole bunch of people that don't
normally get lightsabers got to fight
with lightsabers it was a really nice
spin on the Sail Barge fight during
Return of the Jedi where r2 ejects
Luke's lightsaber he ejects like three
or four and like everybody in the party
gets lightsabers this is why you need to
be reading the Star Wars comic because
of stuff like this if you are looking
for a really cool Star Wars comic to
read and you've already read this one or
you're just not really digging it
there's another new Star Wars title
called Vader down that you should
definitely check out everybody just hold
on a little bit longer and if you're
wondering when people are gonna start
posting their reviews like websites and
stuff that's gonna start on Wednesday so
just beware for spoilery Star Wars
reviews if you're trying to avoid that
kind of stuff while you wait for my next
video to post you can click here for all
my Star Wars trailer videos and you can
click here to learn all about Valyrian
swords the closest thing you get to
light sabers on Game of Thrones so thank
you so much for watching everybody I'll
see you guys tonight
you